los daños se extienden por cientos de
metros en bueno baja una ciudad que fue
tomada por tropas rusas y separatistas
hace un mes y medio el 70% de los
edificios han sido destruidos al menos
parcialmente por las bombas en el patio
de esta escuela los proyectiles dejaron
cráteres en el suelo los cristales de
varias ventanas están destrozados y sin
embargo la escuela ha abierto esta es la
única hoy vamos a centrarnos en varias
zonas naturales y sus nombres en rusia
la política de rusificación comienza en
las escuelas las clases se imparten
ahora en ruso y aunque muchos alumnos de
esta escuela hablan ruso en casa algunos
siguen diciendo que el cambio ha sido
difícil
para la geometría las palabras son
diferentes totalmente diferentes
asociamos siembras y tienes que aprender
todo desde cero en ruso es difícil
en el coro del barrio cercano los niños
practican canciones rusas patrióticas
ensayan para el día de la victoria que
se celebra el 9 de mayo en rusia y
conmemora el final de la segunda guerra
mundial
la bandera rusa ondea ahora sobre el
ayuntamiento que aún conserva las
huellas del reciente conflicto algunos
residentes dicen estar contentos con la
toma de posesión rusa y rusia es rusia
es nuestra hermana es nuestra madre como
turco
otros en cambio prefieren no hacer
comentarios
es difícil no lo sé en el mercado y en
las tiendas la moneda ucraniana sigue
siendo aceptada pero los rublos están
cada vez más en circulación mientras la
ciudad lucha por recuperarse algunos
miran a rusia para que les ayuden en la
reconstrucción
si estamos con rusia espero que nos
ayude a reconstruir todo porque no lo
conseguiremos solos la versión rusa es
que han liberado a bueno baja y otras
zonas ahora son parte de la
autoproclamada república popular de
donges